l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a nessuno
video sono fa di jane hanno messo un
braccialetto dei carcerati
oggi siamo i nuovi ragazzi come avete
potuto le ragazze però che voi non
abbiate dei seri problemi di vista
savino location diversa dal solito
perché di solito io faccio vito in
camera mia questa volta ragazzo ho fatto
il passo da gigante mi sono
completamente spostato infatti mi sono
spostato da qui a qui ma ci devi fare un
mega episodio di nuovo di scartato dei
fatti quindi ragazzi dopo aver passato
due ora di incastrare questi fatti tutti
alla tetris direi che possiamo
cominciare con i prima sarà una cosa
veramente lunga almeno per me comincia a
permettere la storia ragazzi porto da un
pacco e norme che frase brutta da dire
di solito parte la più piccola ma
stavolta no stavolta volevo aprire
questo ragazzo io vorrei capire perchè è
una lampada vedersi così spero che non
lo sia o mio dio chi è cosa troppo
figlia trovate una mia starttext ansa la
mia stessa maglietta di adesso come che
ci facevi a sapere che aver indossato la
maglietta è la cosa più bella che abbia
mai visto
vado veloce lega perché non miliardo da
scartare sono finiamo più
o mio dio no no va bè questo no questo
no ma perché ragazza vera shumpert cos'è
questa cosa mio dio è la madonna perché
c'è un disegno di minuto non
completamente nudo ma quasi carafa vj
solo isabel isabella isab grazie
isabella grazie sono contento di farci
questo effetto venezia poi se il mio
idolo saluti da gemma e matilde tutti i
miei amici che ti seguono ps6 bellissimo
posto berretto sexy la ghirlanda sono al
limite della sec saggin è pronto è un
miracolo che non sia spargendo giornali
ovunque ragazzi c'è mai successo se
questo opa ho paura ad aprire le scatole
neve lo dico cristo santo la sua casa è
sta roba è la cosa più bella la brutta
allo stesso tempo che abbia mai visto
io non so come ho fatto vivere senza
fino adesso non scalano uno scorpione
dentro una no vabbè ma che schifo e per
concludere una un baffo bellissimo no
vabbè questo questo mi rifiuto
ufficialmente dimette c'è una era una
barbie con su scritto fa vj sulle tette
grazie partenza epica così grazie mi
state prendendo per il futuro
[Musica]
ma basta cazzo porca [ __ ] ragazzi
guardate dorare di preciso st cagata di
giornali sui giornali che sono quattro
ore e mezzo di giornali che sto aprendo
ci posso credere
sì sì sì sì sì sì orgogliosa passione
credo che ci sia passione desiderio
anche nell'infilare tutta questa carta
su per il culo il prossimo fatto
ragazzino basta e vi prego non lo farò
ma in set di rubbia di lady gaga
berna va beh questo non lo devi spiegare
ma io mi ha regalato una scatola di
cuori con dei baci dentro lenta di
sedurmi dopo che tattica ma non ci casco
come ultimo ragazzi della carta igienica
in pacchetti nola per questo è il
geniale la madonna ragazzo e questo lo
adorano perché i ragazzi ma e paci così
sono troppo contesta figata della non ci
voglio credere
ragazzi questo è bellissimo perché mi
serviva per un motivo c'è
la mia vita è completa del suo ghiaccio
ma perché c'è un reggiseno che ho paura
che sia usato quindi lo non lo tocco un
tanga che anche questo forse non penso
pero non lo sia usato quanto hanno
questo è bellissimo
oh mio dio l'ho trovato la mia ragione
di vita e per ultimo ragazzi c'è la
calza della befana che leggermente in
ritardo vabbè ma si apprezzano sempre
dei dolci tranquilla è cosa per michele
al rifornimento a un pocket coffee c'e
ragazzi fatemi capire no vabbè ma che
cazzo ma perché ok ok perfetto
ci vediamo ragazzi alla prossima sono
veri purtroppo magari me li scambiano
per verità anche una farà o meno di
questo vi fa paura ragazze sono più
bello di quando mi alzo la mattina
comunque c'è lì capii capelli sono più
in ordini dagli ultimi tre poi non ce la
posso già finito ringraziando iddio un
matitone immigrati non ho il cuore
capito l'utilità di questa ragazzi prova
voi e olio cos'è un mio amico mi ha
cassato questo tono dei codici dei
codici place ma funzionano usato grazie
vado col prossimo che di sicuro se ma
sono convinto che sarà molto meglio
usato anche questo è vabbè dai proviamo
sicuramente con l'ultimo solo più
fortunata
cioè se usato anche questa è che cazzo
dopo o parchi e manca peppa pig grave
giorni mi sembrava strano di un averne
trovata ancora una veramente comunque
ragazzi ha concluso fino scarta giorno
ha seriamente dovete vedere una cosa
perché è indecente la papa parte il mio
cappello e guardate che cazzo di ciò il
mondo praticamente qua dentro ci sono
pacchi o luca è stato bello ma veramente
perché sto facendo il tipo self i
navigli che state a dio mio che comodità
la sedia che cazzo di capelli ciò basta
per non ne posso veramente più vista è
stato bello però è questo quello di
concluso quell'episodio ragazzi siccome
mi hanno mandato questo che ancora non
riesco a capire il perché qual è il
vostro sogno erotico su di me di preciso
fatemelo sapere perché sono curioso
adesso devo andare a denunciare chi mi
ha regalato questo quindi ragazzi 6
video e fatemi sapere nei commenti se il
video è piaciuto so dovete mi piace che
la pace
iscrizione sono riflessioni che ci
vediamo al prossimo video belle ragazze